[Music]
on this sunday night
a leading killer kovid 19 is becoming
one of the top causes of death in
alberta
death is a late metric death is a very
late metric
is the province too late with its
restrictions patiently waiting
for the vaccine we don't want to waste a
single drop of this liquid gold
how long before lockdowns can be eased
in ontario
plus former prime minister brian
mulroney's health scare
while on vacation and oh christmas tree
where are you the shortage of this tall
tradition
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us today is the day the first doses of
the covid19 vaccine are slated to arrive
in canada
a pivotal point in this pandemic here's
what we can tell you about the initial
rollout
the first batch of the pfizer biontech
vaccine 30
000 doses will be divvied up among 14
distribution sites across the country
each jurisdiction has decided who gets
the vaccine first
that includes frontline healthcare
workers and long-term care residents
shots could be administered in some
places as early as tomorrow
it's what everyone has been waiting for
but some provinces are still struggling
to bring down the number of new
infections
ontario saw just over 1600 new cases in
the past 24 hours
a slight drop from yesterday quebec
reported nearly 2
000 new cases today and it now has
recorded at least 7 500 covert related
deaths
since march alberta recorded its
deadliest day of the pandemic
with 22 lives lost and there were more
than 1700 new infections
reported in the province alberta has
more than a quarter of canada's active
cases
despite having only about 12 percent of
the country's population
and that has forced the provincial
government to implement new restrictions
starting today hair salons are closed
bars and restaurants have moved to take
out only
but as heather yorks west explains
health experts still believe
hospitals can expect an increasing
number of patients
and families can expect to see more
loved ones die
roger maxwell died last week of covid
19.
the correctional peace officer worked at
the fort saskatchewan correctional
center near edmonton
one of more than 200 facilities in the
province experiencing
an outbreak once you get to this level
of community transmission there's a much
higher likelihood that any one person in
any given group
might be infectious and not yet aware
that they're infected
approximately 700 albertans have now
died of covet 19
making it the sixth leading cause of
death in the province
coming behind dementia chronic heart
disease lung cancer
copd and heart attacks but with more
than 20
000 active covet cases alberta will see
additional deaths in the coming weeks
death is a late
metric death is a very late metric so
when you start to see a rise in cases
you wouldn't expect to see a rise in
hospitalizations
for a few weeks after that and then you
wouldn't even expect to see a rise in
deaths
until a couple of weeks after that
alberta doctors began
calling for tougher restrictions in
early november but it wasn't until this
past week that the premier agreed to
close things like restaurants casinos
and hair salons
businesses were given four days before
measures took effect sunday
making the lead up to the shutdown
incredibly busy
for me personally i just jammed 13 days
working days into
four 15 to 18 hour days it's hoped the
restrictions will reduce the number of
new infections but with christmas less
than two weeks away
the stakes remain very high indoor
gatherings are a leading cause of
transmission
and even if just a small number of
people ignore the rules
kova 19 numbers could continue to rise
my recommendation is
remember keep your contacts as as low as
possible and preferably nothing outside
of your household
we all have our part to play hospitals
in edmonton have had to cancel
non-urgent surgeries and other
procedures as they get ready for more
covid19 patients
the number of people in need of hospital
care already expected to double
before new year's eve heather york's
west global news
calgary ontario is set to begin its
first round of coven 19 vaccinations on
tuesday but there still
aren't enough doses to go around to
everyone so it will be months before the
true scope of this national vaccination
plan will be realized
that has health experts and politicians
warning canadians not to let their guard
down
here's morgan campbell you don't have to
look very far outside of toronto to find
those
traveling beyond the city limits to
fulfill holiday shopping lists
they are lined up inside and outside of
malls
where shopping is allowed hopefully we
can all
learn to wear masks and you know
properly socially distance and hopefully
that helps curve
the spread sooner rather than later but
relief may be
on the horizon ontario expects to
receive 6 000
doses of pfizer's covid19 vaccine
on monday and will give them to
approximately
2500 healthcare workers at a hospital in
toronto and another
in ottawa we don't want to waste a
single drop of this liquid gold
and we need to make sure that we have
backup upon backup on backup
with about 14 000 doctors in the
province another 100
000 nurses and 70 thousand people
connected to long-term care the rollout
process
is expected to take a while this will
have no effect
in the short term we need to get
hundreds of thousands of doses
quickly to have any sort of meaningful
effect which is why canadians
can't let their guards down we've got a
hard couple of months
if not more looping at us and it's easy
to lose sight of that fact when we're
focused on the miracle of the vaccine
a major concern among some ontario
mayors
people will become more relaxed with
public health measures
the major problem is is that people have
to stop
having those social gatherings we're
going to have to do it probably for
another 12 months but be patient
we're on the path to recovery medical
experts believe that the smaller
shipments of the vaccines will actually
allow provinces more of an opportunity
to iron out logistical concerns
moving forward meanwhile the province of
ontario is expected to release more
details
monday once the vaccine arrives here on
canadian soil
robin morgan campbell in oshawa ontario
thanks morgan
the first doses of the pfizer biantec
vaccine rolled out of a plant in
michigan this morning
headed to health care workers across the
united states
but it could be months before they're
all vaccinated and the numbers in the
u.s are overwhelming
over the past week there has been an
average of 208
000 cases per day as jennifer johnson
reports
operation warp speed can't move fast
enough
as the first vaccine doses were loaded
onto trucks bound for desperate
healthcare workers
pfizer employees cheered the trucks left
the company's freezer farm in michigan
under the protection of u.s marshals a
military-like operation to battle this
pandemic
we're shipping 2.9 million doses of
vaccine so
whenever they get them in arms that's
2.9 million people getting vaccinated
the freight trucks are specially
outfitted to keep the vaccines in
extreme low temperatures
custom critical written on the side of
the fedex trucks
they're the highest priority of anything
that we're carrying in our system
the vaccines are being sent over 600
predetermined sites
inoculations of healthcare workers will
start monday or tuesday
but it will take weeks possibly months
for everyone on the front line to be
protected
to get our staff done we're looking at
getting into february
and then that's even before we can get
to our patients so we've got a long haul
operation warp speed hopes to have 40
million doses delivered by the end of
december
as you all know this is our peak season
so this is the busiest time for us but
you know we made capacity in our network
because we knew these vaccines were so
important
later this month teams from cvs and
walgreens pharmacies
will start administering vaccines to
residents in 75
000 nursing homes and long-term
facilities according to the cdc guidance
to the states and the pharmacies if they
can't begin
until 12 21 they'll work through getting
the consents in place from the
individual patients and their family
members
as pfizer stalked windows the fda says
it will move as quickly as possible in
approving the moderna vaccine and others
but the biggest challenge could still be
convincing people to get the shots
all of them are 100 percent efficient in
terms of blocking hospitalization
and serious illness so take whichever
you can get first and the sooner you
will be protected
healthcare experts are again begging
americans to stay vigilant
concerned about surge upon surge of the
deadly virus
now and after the christmas holiday
jennifer johnson
global news washington germany announced
a hard
nationwide lockdown aimed at curbing
infections
starting on wednesday all non-essential
shops schools and hair salons will close
private gatherings will remain limited
to no more than five people from two
households
despite the country's early success in
containing the virus
a recent partial lockdown has failed to
prevent a rising cases
the latest figures show cases have
increased by 20
000 for a total of 1.3 million confirmed
cases
and more than 21 000 deaths since the
beginning
of the pandemic doctors treating brian
mulrooney say the former prime minister
is expected to make a full recovery
while rooney was rushed to a florida
hospital friday night
and underwent emergency surgery in a
tweet his daughter
caroline mulroney says her father is
feeling better
and is now resting at home sources close
to the family say his wife mila noticed
something
wasn't right with her husband and called
9-1-1 the mulroneys are vacationing in
palm beach florida
where the family has wintered for
several years
besides coven 19 cases alberta has the
highest rate of syphilis in canada
now researchers at the u of a are trying
a strategy
it's a two for one test that also looks
at hiv
asu lingo reports the results take just
five minutes
so the patient can get treatment sooner
two new rapid tests for hiv and syphilis
involve a finger prick and a plastic
device
similar to a home pregnancy test it has
a
dot that will show up on the surface
and then two other dots if the test is
positive for syphilis or hiv
infectious diseases specialist amita
singh is leading a u of a
study to test both tests for potential
health canada approval
screening 1500 at-risk people in
edmonton and northern alberta
so i'm really excited to give this a try
here in edmonton where we have
incredibly high rates of syphilis right
now edmonton has the highest syphilis
rates in the country with more than half
of alberta's 1600 cases
in the first nine months of this year in
that same period
23 babies were born with syphilis in
alberta
another seven were stillbirths in 2019
edmonton also made up nearly half of the
province's 250 cases
of hiv if you have an infection with
syphilis
you're much more likely to get hiv if
you're exposed at the same time as well
the rapid tests produce results in five
minutes
then patients are treated for syphilis
on the spot
standard lab tests can take two weeks
for results currently in some settings
we
lose about 20 percent of people to
follow up so they don't return for a
test result
or the um
there's a significant delay before
they're located and offered treatment
syphilis often affects hard-to-reach
populations people with unstable housing
mental health issues or addictions dr
singh says
sexually transmitted infections and high
rates of
meth use in edmonton go hand in hand
and we know that stimulant drugs change
and influence people's sexual behavior
untreated syphilis can lead to vision
and hearing loss
heart attack and dementia it can cause
developmental delays in babies
if they survive tsulingo global news
edmonton hundreds of students have been
abducted
in nigeria a group of armed men targeted
an all-boys school
police say about 200 students managed to
escape but as many as 400 are still
missing
those who did get away say the gunman
demanded money and ransacked their
lockers
government troops have reportedly found
the area where the gunmen are holding
the students hostage
parents have been gathering at the
school in the hopes of learning the fate
of their children the uk and the
european union have
once again agreed to extend post-brexit
trade talks
after missing today's deadline a call
was held between british prime minister
boris
johnson and the eu's commission
president
they insist there is hope that a deal
will be reached but they can't agree on
fishing quotas
and the eu is concerned about
competition with british companies
getting financial support
from the government i'm afraid we're
still
very far apart on some key things but
where there's life
there's hope we're going to keep talking
to see what we can do the uk
certainly won't be walking away from the
talks i think people would expect us to
to go the extra mile technically the
deal is supposed to be done by december
31st
the prime minister admits that likely
won't happen but says british
negotiators will not walk away from the
table
tonight john le carre is being
remembered as one of the best
storytellers of our time
the master spy author passed away at the
age of 89
from pneumonia there is a mole
right at the top of british intelligence
his fans may remember his book tinker
taylor soldier spy being parlayed into a
blockbuster
his real name was david cornwell and his
career spanned
25 novels many were best sellers
a humanitarian and giant of literature
he was awarded sweden's olaf palm prize
this year
for his extraordinary contributions to
democracy
he gave the prize money to doctors
without borders
coming up kate breton cut off the
turbulent times
for university students
cape breton nova scotia is feeling cut
off there are no commercial flights
flying to or from the island
and the region is home to a major
university 60 percent of its student
population comes from abroad
tonight there are concerns that number
will take a nosedive with a lack of air
transportation
here's ross lord as an island connected
to the mainland by a causeway
cape breton can feel remote even more so
now after both
west jet and air canada have cut air
service
eliminating commercial flights after
january 10th the news
about the reduction to essentially
nothing of commercial air service
for cape breton island is essentially
catastrophic
air canada says it regrets the impact on
customers but says without specific
financial support from government
it's increasingly difficult to operate
in the pandemic
the airline says it's carrying less than
eight percent of normal passenger
volumes
air canada's cutbacks are the third
round of reductions in atlantic canada
in the past six months they leave
halifax down from 21 destinations within
canada last year
to six st john new brunswick is left
with no commercial flights
it's the same result on cape breton
island leaving travelers four
hours away from the nearest airport even
longer in bad weather
and that may impact cape breton
university more than 60 percent of
students come
from other parts of the world the influx
of international students
has spurred population growth on the
island for the first time in decades
a success story that could turn sour i
think
losing our report will not only affect
the ability of the current students to
travel
freely but also impact the decision of
the future students
to come to gabriel the student union and
political representatives
are calling on the federal government to
restore commercial flights
they hope the stoppage is temporary that
the end of the pandemic
marks a return to normal air service but
that's far from certain
you have to wonder whether or not what
we've seen happen here with our regional
local airport may be an early warning
signal of things that may happen across
the country
so everybody should be concerned about
this more anxiety about the pandemic's
ripple effect
and how long it will last ross lord
global news
still ahead will business trips bounce
back
why air travel faces a steep price if
they don't
despite the introduction of rapid cova
tests at some airports and the prospect
of vaccines
air travel is still floundering airlines
say they will lose
200 billion dollars in 2020 and 2021.
business travel is a key component of
the losses and microsoft founder bill
gates predicts
corporate travel will never return to
pre-coveted levels
redmond shannon explains why that could
make flying more expensive
for all of us as 2020 progressed
the outlook for airlines only got worse
they say
widespread airport testing is needed to
encourage
customers to return but even after the
pandemic the industry may never be the
same again
well my prediction would be that over
50 percent of business travel and
over 30 percent of days in the office
will go away microsoft founder bill
gates might well say that
his company and those like zoom have
helped replace the business trip
with the virtual meeting but others
agree it's part of a permanent
trend intercompany meetings seem to be a
really good candidate because
so much of what's happening with zoom
right now is that
it is the activity which does not
involve clients
and seems to be readily accepted by by
employees
jay sorensen's aviation consultancy has
predicted a permanent drop of
19 to 36 percent of business travel
specifically in areas like commuting i.t
support and research work
first class cabins are not being filled
with
passengers paying three five ten
thousand dollars for a ticket like it
was pre-pandemic
and that will become a huge problem for
many airlines who rely on that revenue
to subsidize cheap tickets
for the rest of us 300 transatlantic
fares that we're seeing now
can't possibly exist and the airlines
stay in business and they'll have to
make up for that some way and that
probably means
higher economy fares it could reshape
airline business models
forcing them to shift focus toward trips
that are
irreplaceable the thrill of being
someplace of tasting local food
of the smells of the sights of the wind
in your hair
is can't be replaced by technology so
one of the long lasting effects of the
pandemic may simply be
that our vacations cost a little bit
more or become
a little more rare redmond shannon
global news
london up next as kova 19 cuts down
businesses
why are christmas tree sales going up
many businesses are getting hit hard in
the pandemic especially during what
should be a lucrative holiday season
but the christmas tree industry is
somehow booming across north america
it's performing so well sales this
season are already
outperforming last year's numbers so
what's behind the growing demand
mike truly explains pandemic christmas
tree time
i thought at the time it was the covid19
cabin fever
after all who cuts down a christmas tree
in mid-november
and here we go but as it turns out we
were ahead of the curve
people were there um even a week before
my farms were opening people were
stopping in knocking on the door do you
think i could cut a tree
so if you're carrying this no we dragged
and bagged our tree and not long
afterwards the farm put up a familiar
sign
closed for the season some farms shut
before december 1st
that's never happened before
the industry started seeing the signs in
july when it became evident the 2.2
million trees canada exports to the us
every year
weren't going to be enough drysdale's
tree farm about an hour outside toronto
for one
declined to sell all their stock to the
u.s at inflated prices
i want to support those people that have
supported us the numbers aren't in but
it's expected the increase in sales will
be around 25 30 percent
and yes it's all believed to be related
to covid in one way or the other
christmas tree farmers are telling me
this is a first of them being closed
so that they can actually enjoy the
season as well because
normally right normally we're so busy
we're just going through the motions
um and a lot of farms are open until
december 24th who knew the hottest toy
of the season
wasn't a toy at all mike durley global
news toronto
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm robin gill tonight your
canada
is winnipeg we'd love to see your photos
so email them to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be here tomorrow have a great night
you